bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale résultats des élections
départementales sur france 3 jusqu'à
13h45 pour décrypter les chiffres avec
moi eric sicaud pour détailler également
l'analyse sur les départements de la
saône et loire et de l'yonne et puis et
lilian melet avec vous nous décrypterons
ceux de la nièvre et de la côte-d'or
voyons justement département par
département ce qui s'est passé hier
commençons par à la saône et loire trois
binômes élu au premier tour ce qu'il
faut retenir de ce premier tour avec
caroline jour es1 l'issue du premier
tour avec 38 % des voix dans le canton
de louhans
le président sortant du département de
saône-et-loire et me chanteront n'est
pas sûr d'être réélu
son binôme avec sabine schaeffer est
devancé par celui de la droite
départementale qui obtient 48 de 8 5%
des voix
à digoin ballottage défavorable
également à la majorité départementale
fabien genêt et edith perraudin ont 41
2% des suffrages 28 % qu on le devine au
ps même situation dans le canton chalon
de un duel au second tour entre binôme
de la majorité départementale et du ps
le front national étant éliminé au
premier tour affaire réglée au premier
tour pourquoi quand on chauffe ayew le
binôme de la droite départementale est
élu avec 53 18 % des voix idem à
charolles avec 51% des voix
enfin cluny a élu au premier tour avec
52 % des voix loudine homme de gauche a
pas moins de huit triangulaire pour
terminer en saône et loire au second
tour où comme à cuiseaux par exemple les
binômes de gauche sont en position
favorable
gros plan sur louhans le canton du
président sortant le socialiste
rémi chaintron et menacé son binôme
n'arrive qu'en deuxième position de
grosse déception sur les terres d'arnaud
montebourg
l'ump a même frôlé l'élection dès le
premier tour bintou sidibé et jean louis
saint tin ce n'est pas une vague bleue
marine est une vague bleue tout court
qui a submergé le canton de louhans rémi
chaintron président du conseil général
sortant et candidat ps s'est largement
fait distancer par les jeunes candidats
de l'ump au moment du dépouillement
très vite le duo anthony valdo et
mathilde chalumeau vire en tête au fur
et à mesure que s'ouvrent les enveloppes
un constat s'impose l'ump est le grand
vainqueur de se prononcer on frôle la
barre des 50% on a peut-être là 48 49 %
bon c'est un très bon score
après si on doit faire à un second tour
est bien bron va tout donner dans la
semaine qui vient pour je pense qu'on va
continuer à avoir la même démarche de
proximité et continuer
ce message qu'on veut passer de dire de
rendre à ce mandat son côté de proximité
on a fait ça pendant toute la campagne
du premier tour et on va continuer plus
de 48% pour la droite à peine 30% pour
la gauche c'est la douche froide
le parti socialiste pourrait voir la
président du conseil général lui
échapper même dans la commune de montrer
où madame le maire était candidate c'est
encore l'ump qui arrive premier avec
cinq voix d'avancé dans la bresse sur
les terres de montebourg la gauche n'a
pas réussi à rassembler les faits
montebourg n'a peut-être pas forcément
eu lieu voilà il est
il a pas je pense pas a lieu ce n'est
plus le même là même
on a le même engagement je pense à la
population je crois qu'effectivement on
paye aussi une certaine défiance
vis-à-vis du parti socialiste je n'ai
jamais caché mon étiquette j'ai toujours
ma carte et je la garderais j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais plus socialiste
que beaucoup d'autres et donc c'est vrai
que ça va être c'est un 2e tour
compliqué mais vous savez en politique
on a l'habitude des 2e tour compliqué et
donc on va tout faire pour rattraper le
retard
une nouvelle qui second tour se jouera
entre l'ump et le ps le fn qui malgré sa
percée dans les petites communes n'a
obtenu que 20 % des voix
pas assez pour se maintenir dimanche
prochain en saône-et-loire donc trois
binômes élu dès le premier tour dimanche
prochain il y aura huit triangulaire
avec à chaque fois la présence du front
national eric sicaud la saône et loire
département de bourgogne où subsiste
plus grand suspense et oui bah c'est le
département ont fait où l'on note le
plus grand nombre de paradoxes l'élément
le plus frappant on l'a vu c'est le
score faible du président sortant rémy
chaintron halle où on voit mal comment
le canton pourrait échapper au binôme de
droite et pourtant la gauche résiste
dans le département même si elle recule
nettement par rapport à 2011
elle reste en tête avec plus de 38 et
demi pour cent des suffrages devant la
droite 37 6 et le front national 23,5
elle réussit même à décrocher un canton
c'est unique en bourgogne à cluny où
elle a pourtant perdu la vie l'an
dernier et lé seul en lice
à saint vallier dans un duel entre le
front de gauche et le ps on compte
également huit triangulaire plutôt
favorable à la gauche sauf à pierre de
bresse
la droite elle progresse certes mais
relativement peu en pourcentage
seulement trois points de plus qu'en
2011 elle arrive toutefois en tête dans
15 cantons elle a déjà deux élus à
charolles et chauffailles
et elle met la gauche en difficulté à
louer on l'a vu mais aussi à chalon 2,3
à digoin à autun et à montceau quant au
fn il progresse mais il reste en deçà de
ses performances nationales
sur le papier les blocs de gauche et de
droite sont quasiment à égalité au 2e
tour la mobilisation des électorats des
deux blocs sera crucial état des lieux
dans l'yonne à présent avec un binôme
élu au premier tour il y aura quatre
triangulaires 16
ul et plusieurs interrogations dans son
départ dans ce département
y aura-t-il des élus front national qui
peut espérer briguer le fauteuil de
président détenu actuellement par à lui
dit andré villiers éléments de réponse
avec théo souvent dans l'yonne vague
bleue marine
le front national s'est qualifié presque
partout pour le second tour arrivant
même en tête dans dix cantons sur 21
c'est le cas dans celui de pont sur
yonne où le binôme odoul ferrand obtient
une large avance sur la gauche et la
droite ce sera l'une des quatre
triangulaires incertaine dimanche
prochain le front national en tête aussi
à joigny avec quatre voix d'avancé sur
le binôme d'union de la gauche
il y aura trois duels fn ps au second
tour dans l'yonne et 12 duels entre le
fn et la droite comme à joux la ville où
le président sortant du conseil général
lui d y entrer villiers arrive en tête
avec 41 24 % des voix devant le tandem
frontiste 29 99% à droite le sénateur
ump jean baptiste lemoyne fait mieux
puisqu'il est le seul élu dès le premier
tour dans le département avec delphine
grammy ils récoltent plus de 59% des
suffrages dans le canton de gastines et
en bourgogne
de fait jean baptiste lemoyne prend
l'ascendant dans la course à la
présidence du département
en revanche rude soirée pour la gauche
dans l'yonne
même dans son bastion d'un vallon où le
duo ps se classe troisième et se
retrouve engagé dans une triangulaire à
haut risque au second tour exemple d'un
département où le front national a
réussi son implantation s'est donc
pont-sur-yonne dans le nord du
département
le fn est en tête et pourrait même
l'emporter tous les regards se tournent
donc vers le conseiller socialiste
sortant arrivé troisième lui pourtant
espère encore gagner
vas-y djaouti et cédric le poitevin des
candidats tendu les traits tirés scotché
toute la soirée à leur portable en quête
de résultats soir d'élection dans ce
bureau de pont-sur-yonne le fn
nourrissait de grandes ambitions pour ce
canton
arrivé en tête le binôme au double
ferrante sera bien au second tour
ce soir c'est un vote d'espoir votre
d'espoir
les électeurs du canton qui par leur
vote voulu protéger le département ont
voulu protéger les politiques sociales
ont voulu donner un signal fort envoyé
un signal fort à la gauche de manuel
valls au gouvernement et puis à la caste
ump s derrière le fn le binôme de droite
déjà une victoire pour grégory dorte le
jeune maire depuis à peine un an de
pause sur yonne mais face à la menace
frontiste
il appelle le candidat de gauche à la
responsabilité faut faire barrage au fn
monsieur bourreau a priori souhaite se
maintenir je pense qu'il devrait écouter
des consignes si je peux me permettre au
niveau national qui est de se désister
pour un rassemblement républicain pour
un front républicain
arrivait en troisième position le
conseil général sortant athènes tout
juste le seuil pour se maintenir au
second tour
la menace de voir une victoire du front
national est réelle mais le candidat
socialiste a pourtant décidé de se
maintenir
on a des chances réelles je vous le dis
quand on additionne les voix de gauche
ont lu devant la droite classique donc
la dynamique peut être créée et elle le
fera elle le sera on fera tout pour le
faire
c'est une situation très tendue mais
justement les situations tendues peuvent
engendrer des vrais choix chez les
électeurs si le ps semble le seul à
disposer de réserves envoie la
triangulaire s'annonce plus
qu'incertaine pour faire la différence
chacun des candidats devra peut-être
aller chercher entre les deux tours les
électeurs qui n'ont pas voté alors
évêque dans l'yonne c'est vraiment la
montée du front national qui marque ce
premier tour bien sûr l'extrême droite
améliore encore son score des
européennes dans le département en
atteignant 32 5%
résultat il est tenté dans dix cantons
restent présents dans 19 autres sur
vingt en mordant sur sa droite mais en
réalisant aussi des scores
impressionnants dans d'anciens bastions
de gauche comme à saint florentin ou à
migennes si la gauche ne se désiste pas
à pont-sur-yonne s'il ne se mobilisent
pas pour faire barrage à torigni charny
briennon et migennes et bien le fn est
en mesure de remporter jusqu'à cinq
cantons et donc d'avoir dix élus dans la
future assemblée départementale
la droite elle gardera malgré tout sa
majorité face à une gauche qui perd 10
points par rapport à 2011 et qui ne peut
tabler que sur trois à six victoires
avec toujours le risque d'une division
interne
le sénateur apparenté ump jean baptiste
lemoyne est le seul élu du premier tour
ce qui peut lui laisser une certaine
légitimité pour la présidence mais le
président sortant andré villiers sera
également renforcée de ce premier tour
là où il y avait division de la droite
et bien ce sont ces candidats qui se
sont qualifiés pour le deuxième tour
la nièvre à présent aucun élu hier
dimanche prochain 5 triangulaires et 12
duels
là aussi une forte poussée du front
national sera présent dans 13 des 17
cantons résumé signée elle a besoin
illustration de cette poussée bleu
marine dans le canton de nevers 2 où
l'extrême droite vire en tête avec plus
de 30 % des suffrages
elle sera opposée à la gauche dimanche
prochain le front national qualifié
aussi pour le second tour dans le canton
de cosne-sur-loire le sortant divers
droite michel venot et sa colistière ump
sont en ballottage favorable dans le
canton emblématique de château chinon
peu de suspense la gauche fait la course
en tête
le sortant le socialiste patrice joly
devrait retrouver sans difficulté son
côté de conseiller enfin la gauche
éliminée à cames 6 ou le second tour
mettra en présence le tandem divers
droite ump à face au binôme fonds
national dimanche prochain dans le
canton de corbigny sur ses terres
historiques la gauche pourrait passer de
justesse seulement l'ump et le fn sont
en position de se maintenir
retour sur la soirée d'hier dans ce
canton avec pauline ringenbach et romain
libre le rideau tombe sur le canton de
corbigny au fur et à mesure du
dépouillement
l'hypothèse de la triangulaire semble se
profiler défend le candidat front
national marcel stéphan se fait une
place dans ce canton du morvan
traditionnellement acquis à la gauche
l'ump le ps et le fn se retrouve au
deuxième tour pour une triangulaire
inattendue bien évidemment la situation
était meilleure en duel face à la gauche
évidemment mais bon messieurs bazin et
port élu au premier tour comme c'était
coutume voilà c'est quand même nouveau
est bon il y aura un deuxième tour je
sais pas historiquement mais ça fait
plusieurs décennies que le candidat du
canton de lormes et élu au premier tour
la donne change pour fabien bazin le
candidat ps
il arrive même derrière le candidat ump
à quelques voix près 33,1 % pour
jean-charles rochard 32 9% pour fabien
bazin 25 3% pour marcel stéphan
mais le conseiller sortant ne veut pas
dramatiser ces résultats on est sur des
territoires différents on est sur une
élection différentes il ya aujourd'hui
deux titulaires un homme et une femme on
va réaliser enfin la parité au sein de
l'assemblée départementale ce qui
n'était pas gagné si on était resté sur
un autre un autre mode de scrutin
et puis on a une période on le voit bien
où il ya une perte de sens de repères et
notre travail à nous les élus locaux
c'est justement de redonner ses repères
et ce sens parce que la république c'est
aussi celle des villages
jean-charles rochard termine donc en
tête de ce premier tour mais il a
affiché une mine inquiète toute la
soirée en attendant les derniers
résultats les triangulaires ne sont
jamais idéal parce que on ne peut jamais
savoir comment les abstentionnistes
comment les reports vont pouvoir se
réaliser
c'est assez compliqué ce que je note
c'est que la gauche était partie divisée
et que de nombreuses consignes venues du
front de gauche nous indiqué qu'il
refuserait de se reporter sur le parti
socialiste qui montre bien qu'il ya une
véritable des unions l'ump compte sur
cette division de la gauche au premier
tour pour gagner ce canton le fn n'ayant
que très peu de chances de s'imposer
dans cette configuration il ne me laisse
certains voyaient la perte de la nièvre
par la gauche n'est pas le scénario qui
semble se dessiner
oui on parlait beaucoup de
un bol avec la nièvre le département de
françois mitterrand et sa majorité de
gauche depuis 51 ans et bien après le
premier tour on peut dire qu'on ne se
dirige probablement pas vers une défaite
historique de la gauche et pour
comprendre
on va regarder les chiffres globaux en
les comparant avec les cantonales de
2011 dans une défaite nationale d'une
droite alors au pouvoir les candidats de
droite nivernais avait rassemblé 23 %
des voix
ils en ont fui hier soir dans une large
victoire de leur camp 22%
c'est à dire moins bien dans une
participation en hausse et on le
comprend avec le chiffre du front
national passer de 15 à 26 % des voix il
a bloqué les espoirs de la droite tout
en prenant aussi des électeurs à gauche
ce qui donne un paysage où la gauche
reflux mais résiste ou la droite
progresse mais peu et où le front
national s'est imposé au milieu de
l'échiquier présent au deuxième tour
dans 14 cantons sur 17 avec néanmoins
une question sans alliés aura-t-il des
élus remarquons aussi que le maire de
nevers denis curieux ne sera pas l'
arbitre du scrutin avec ses candidats ce
qui à long terme peut le priver de
sécurité dans sa majorité municipale
enfin la côte d'or avec et 14 duels
dimanche prochain 8 triangulaire et un
binôme élu dès le premier tour à tour
d'horizon avec liseré g
le canton de châtillon sur seine est le
seul à avoir un tandem élu dès le
premier tour valérie bouchehr le maire
ump hubert brigand l'ont emporté avec
52,5 % des voix la droite rassurer dans
l'un de ses fiefs elle confirme aussi sa
position de leadership dans le canton de
montbard marc frot et laurence porte
sont en ballottage favorable face aux
radicaux de gauche marion mongouachon et
patrick molinoz à semur-en-auxois large
avantage au duo martin f du pain et
françois sauvadet à 46%
le président sortant contre 1 1 2e sourd
face à l'extrême droite devrait
logiquement conserver son fauteuil
le fn qui gagne du terrain aussi en côte
d'or à brazey-en-plaine il bascule même
en tête avec 39 4% des voix mettant en
difficulté les tandems de droite et de
gauche l'extrême droite en tête aussi
dans le fief de la gauche à chenôve dans
un duel qui s'annonce serré
la gauche elle résiste bien dans la
capitale régionale en ballottage plus ou
moins favorable dans cinq des six
cantons dijonnais notamment sur dijon 2
le maire alain millot et sa première
adjointe nathalie koenders prennent une
belle avance face à la droite
voyons ce qui se passe dans le canton de
brazey-en-plaine donc avec les villes de
saint jean de losne et soeurs le fn
était arrivé en tête lors des
européennes dans 37 des 38 communes il
confirme ses scores avec près de 40% des
suffrages
hier anne berger et tiphaine pfeiffer
c'était la fête aujourd'hui à
brazey-en-plaine mais pas pour tout le
monde dès le dépouillement des premiers
bulletins la tendance se dessine dernier
quentin et qu'on les résultats des
communes arrivent c'est le candidat du
front national qui a le sourire à côté
du secrétaire départemental du fn sur le
terrain on a des très bons retours
ça s'est très bien passé une bonne
campagne on affaire à des personnes qui
ont un bilan ça peut être positif ou
très négatifs et nous qui est un nom des
choses nouvelles
comme en 2004 et en 2011 dans l'ancien
canton de saint jean de losne une
qualification pour le deuxième tour se
profile pour le candidat fn fasse cette
fois la conseillère générale sortante de
soeur emmanuelle point pas surprise du
scénario
effectivement c'est le scénario que
j'avais imaginé il y avait eu quand même
des élections même si elle était
européenne donc peut-être plus éloignés
de nos concitoyens on sait jamais quelle
part va prendre là je dirais la
notoriété locale
pour autant ça semblait quand même
s'inscrire dans le
dans le périmètre du territoire à
bientôt 20 heures la candidate
socialiste chantal bouveret attend son
colistier alain becker le maire de
seurre elle veut connaître tous les
résultats pour s'exprimer
mais dans les rangs de la gauche on
s'inquiète liang dort pas de révolution
à prévoir non révolution la nouveauté
tout de même ici comme partout c'est la
progression du front national présent
dans seize cantons sur 23
c'est bien dans les zones rurales que le
parti de marine le pen progresse mais
aussi dans les zones urbaines populaires
comme chenôve s'est connus mais plus
nouveau sur les cantons de dijon 3 avec
le quartier des grésillés ou de dijon 6
2 chiffres pour comprendre en 2011 le fn
c'était 12 8% des voix
hier c'était 27,28 et c'est bien la
variable de cette élection parce que si
on compare à nouveau avec 2011 la droite
est quasiment stable dans le département
38,4 des voix contre 38 dans un contexte
national
pourtant plus favorable l'autre
paramètre à retenir en côte d'or c'est
la résistance de la gauche sur ses
bastions de l'agglomération dijonnaise
mais en revanche des pertes de plus en
plus visible sur tout ce qui concerne le
monde rural et hier les débats ont
tourné autour du front républicain
autrement dit comme un faire barrage au
front national désistement consigne de
vote écoutez les réactions de nos
invités hier lors de notre soirée
spéciale chacun en son âme et conscience
votera il est bien évident que nous ne
donnerons pas en tous les cas de mots
d'ordre de vote systématique par un port
sd porter j'occupais je suis choquée
parce que quand on dit que lecteur elle
va le choix bien entendu la liberté
lecteurs mais nous nous sommes élus nous
sommes dans des partis politiques
nous donnons des consignes nous allons
faire des réunions dont le faire des
meetings leur on leur dira rien on leur
dira faites ce que vous voulez
choisissant votre votre âme et
conscience
ça veut dire qu'on prend risque demain
d'avoir effectivement des élus puisqu'on
nationale le procès général partout où
on peut battre le candidat du fn ça sera
le rôle du premier secrétaire de la
négociation bien sûr et bien nos
candidats doivent appeler à voter pour
la droite républicaine pour la droite
républicaine contre le fn mais le retour
c'est normal c'est que on en attend
d'eux mêmes
feng ne doit pas être surtout pas le
premier parti de france est aujourd'hui
ne peux pas le dire ne peux pas
l'affirmer et je pense que c'est une
grande victoire
il faut que ça se confirme nous on est
en position très claire notre bureau
fédéral s'était prononcé il ya quelques
semaines déjà à faire battre le fn
partout où ça c'est une une position de
principe
là où nous ne sommes pas au deuxième
tour on discute même pas cet éclair donc
de ce côté là on est effectivement
limpide dans nos orientations
on n'a jamais dit qu'on ne voterai pas
avec l'un ou avec l'autre mais c'est
dans l'intérêt général qu'il faut
arrêter de stigmatiser
j'entendais je combats j'aimerais bien
ludovic rochette mais on doit pas
combattre le ps on doit travailler avec
eux parfois on doit pouvoir travailler
avec d'autres il ya des gens compétents
des deux côtés travaillons ensemble
mon combat il est clairement d'abord
contre la gauche parce qu'on le voit
bien le front national n'est pas en
situation de gagner ici en côte d'or
naturellement la majorité donc le combat
elle est clairement contre la gauche
nous reviendrons sur ces appels lancés
sur ces tractations en cours dans la
suite de notre édition spéciale nous
retrouvons en bourgogne dans une demi
heure avec notamment un débat sur le
canton de montbard avec laurence porte
et patrick molinoz d'ici là rendez-vous
sur france 3 point fr à tout à l'heure